Hmm,
no doubt that there has become a growing
concern about the income disparity in
the United States up.
Ceos are making greater incomes and ever
before and the gap between what ceos
were making and the lowest paid workers
in those companies are making is
increasing.
And there's no doubt that after 30 or 40
years of a war on poverty,
we still have a great deal of poverty in
the United States and we are the
wealthiest country in the world.
Clearly and other countries in the
world,
developing countries,
emerging countries,
the poverty level is far greater than
even here.
I'm not sure that increasing taxes on
private equity is going to solve all
these problems.
I do believe though that Congress needs
to look at how to reform the tax code in
ways that does make everything work a
little bit more fairly.
For example,
right now the tax code is 10,000 pages
or more.
It's virtually incomprehensible at are
from the former head of the irs is,
is,
uh,
as a,
a employee and he cannot fill out his
own tax returns.
And I don't doubt of any,
a former head of the irs or current head
of the irs can fill out their own tax
returns because it's too complicated.
I think we need to simplify the system
much better.
And I think with simplification,
I think would come greater equity.
That's one of the things we should do,
but there's no doubt that the income
disparity in our country has increased
and we should do some things to,
to deal with it as soon as we can.